ba2 another type of omicron no one is
really surprised as long the virus
continues to multiply new mutation will
fall guarantee that is the lifestyle of
the virus but this one is a sub variant
so what does that mean the regular
omicron we've been dealing with is ba1
you can kind of think of them as sisters
in a family that they're related to each
other they have a common parent that
they both were derived from but they're
slightly different from each other ba2
has different mutations and experts say
we don't yet know enough about it it's
picking up speed in places like the uk
india and denmark where it's the most
dominant strain we've detected it since
november canada's top doctor says more
than a hundred cases have been
identified here and public health is
monitoring closely international data
suggests that it could potentially have
an increased
advantage on spread but that doesn't
seem to be any specific increase
in
hospitalizations or
the severe outcomes it may be more
subtle but it needs to be watched needs
to be studied the sub-variant has picked
up the nickname stealth omicron which
this virologist calls misleading calling
it the stealth variant implies that it
somehow
acquired
sneaky super powers that it doesn't have
if you have ba2 a pcr test will still
tell you you're covet positive it's just
not able to detect the specific
sub-variant sequencing is needed for
that for most people though
i don't think they really care which
particular sub-lineage of the omicron
variant they're infected with because it
doesn't really change what they need to
be doing next at friday's briefing dr
tam stressed that while we may have seen
the peak of this wave across the country
coming down the other side still means
many infections and ba2 could be part of
that descent
abigail beeman global news ottawa